today walker furniture resumed its home  for the holidays delivery now the  program  delivers furniture to families in need  who were nominated by friends and family  now those deliveries typically happen  just right before christmas it's a great  way to ring in the holidays for those  folks but  it was cut short because of the pandemic  so today they began delivering to the  remaining 24  families i'm happy um i  always believe anytime you get something  new you know it's going to bring us  even more peace new beginnings and  happiness  so i can just like start fresh this is a  brand new year  for us megan lawrence was nominated by  her son's fifth grade teacher  who wanted to help make sure their  entire family actually had a  bed to sleep on